so Donald Trump is skipping seat back
I think somebody told him megyn kelly
was going to be here or even worse he
was told there were libertarians who
were gonna be here is the Republican
Party having a nervous breakdown and is
there anything on either side of the GOP
civil war for libertarians to root for
we're here at CPAC the Conservative
Political Action Conference to ask those
questions and more to young conservative
activists from all over the country is
there a candidate in this election left
standing that is stirring your heart at
all um I mean it's kind of like a
reality show at this point but uh I've
got a hoping Trump gets voted off the
island and an old days I don't I line up
suffering at home you're never Trumper
never Trump yet even though the Trump
isn't as conservative in some aspect I
think you would be able to bring trade
back to America you know how we've taken
trade out of this country Senate
overseas so I feel like he would be able
to bring that bad if he if he's putting
tariffs on goods he's going to make your
iPhone a lot more expensive for example
you think that's a good thing I
I'm not that you know I'm not that into
that but I feel that he
my parents are immigrants here I'm a
first-generation from work my dad was
from Syria and my mother was returned so
when you hear politicians this cycle
talk about refugees from Syria how do
you feel about that I don't want them to
come here because of the terrace now if
Obama was bringing over the Christians I
wouldn't have a problem and the only
reason I have a problem with some of the
Muslims is most of them are probably ok
but there's a segment of them that would
probably do us harm we need a president
that won't bring them to the United
States a president that won't grant them
a court appointed lawyer a president
that will send these terrorists where
they belong to Guantanamo Bay Cuba
bomber present United States I would
take apple in the intelligence community
lock them in a room and say you aren't
coming out till you figure this out and
when you come out you're not going to
talk to the press about it and we're not
going to put it on the front page of a
paper we're just going to make sure
we're secure that's what a leader does
and I might put Hannity in the room with
them that'll work that's why I can't
really say anything good about Ted Cruz
or Trump because I don't like either one
of them critically I mean if you're not
backing anybody who's left in the
Republican race who are you sort of
rooting for more than anybody else is
anyone I'm no one really in the
conservative like I liked Rand Paul a
little bit but I've been for Gary
Johnson since day one whatever you
cannot know sure you want to look at it
teens to be best when you fill out of
government so okay so i should vote for
Bernie Sanders as well you're talking
think he got me again this is not a good
advertisement for the republican party
at all but uh so the good news is that a
surprising number of people here at CPAC
need to consider themselves libertarians
or are open to libertarian arguments
bad news is that even they will admit
that their own preferred candidates are
bound to disappoint us all it's been a
weird year for the Republican Party and
I think it's going to keep getting
weirder for reason TV I'm Matt Welch god
bless seat back